le Pérou envisage la castration chimique
obligatoire pour les violeurs d'enfants
c'est le président péruvien Pedro
Castillo qui l'a annoncé après le viol
d'une enfant de 3 ans qui a choqué le
pays la mesure de désormais être
approuvée par le Parlement le Pérou ne
serait pas le premier pays à mettre en
place la castration chimique pour les
auteurs de crime sexuel contre les
mineurs la Pologne a adopté une mesure
de ce type en 2010 la Russie en 2011 la
Corée du Sud en 2012 quelques États
américains l'autorise également depuis
la fin des années 90 mais elle est
rarement appliquée certains pays
n'appliquent pas la castration chimique
copédophile l'autorisant sur tous les
violeurs de manière générale c'est par
exemple le cas de l'Indonésie depuis
2016 et du Pakistan depuis 2020
rappelons que la castration chimique est
un traitement sous forme d'injection ou
de comprimés l'objectif est de simuler
une surproduction testostérone pour
neutraliser la libido lorsqu'on stoppe
le traitement la libido revient la
castration chimique n'est donc pas
définitive certains experts estiment que
la castration chimique ne sert à rien
sans un travail psychologique parallèle
l'ongmestit international qualifie elle
cette méthode de cruel inhumaine et
rétrograde